okay again from voicemail number that number
is two one night show they be you can
call
anytime here was the voicemail with an
interesting out that have under a and a
kind' in cloth or leather your government
shutdown single is in the so it online
ring
what is  there with him pff what a carp
arsenal and with f and error of the
coloring youtube
dequeue love you so good question why
not just make this legal socially
clear about my eyeliner
gotham and metabolic minutes mechanism for
allowing the government shutdown its
provision de aroma de clips  cover my
career was the with and the lagoon is
more expensive not by site one step
okay both sides for the possibility of
garnish your lesson in influence tool and
remember the
since muslims silent operator in the
governor showdown the politician
will be called silent
it's not set their advantage  to make
shutdown single by passing the moment
you what you have shutdown is it sure
to use one you think it's the third
vantage
if it's the other par  ties at stamicarbon
magic give you something to criticize
and creates negotiation points for the
reopening on the driver by you may be
able to achieve tanks de valuable
de jürgen station river toners is the
case of in is so that's why you're never
gonna make up  down and possible or legal
the shutdown is politics or football
british one that both sides and take turns
drawing although i want to both sides at
total e&p house something for cable greens
how did in attempting to us government
shutdown weirs cipollini could success or
it was
many many years but neither site in the
in the week anytime the shutdown can
either
working your favor of backfire art
europe on that you're not point and make
shutdowns  to either side the vantage
any shut it down or to clarify
potential down and that's why a
success
andré clean show you will talk about
how people over a stick
the far the most likely  to share
fake news according to a new study
denver public on the first united
states series to criminalize
magic mushrooms police and janet
muslim solo and the poli's arno
collecting staff and deploy dna
to find out how men in a wedge the
present becoming
and the  lifting a baby and incredibly
disturbing story and one of many new
discuss entrance beans charles pic student